[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
[Musik]
hallo und guten abend hinein es ist der
tag vor dem osterfest für die orthodoxen
christen in der ukraine und in russland
es ist für sie das höchste fest des
jahres ostern in zeiten des krieges ist
die sonne an einem regentag sagt eine
ukrainerin auf der flucht vor den bomben
doch hoffnungen auf eine österliche
waffenruhe sind vergebens die botschaft
von tod und auferstehung in zeiten des
krieges auch heute wieder russische
attacken treffen unter anderem die
ukrainische hafenstadt odessa während
die russische seite nur den beschuss
eines munitionslagers auf einem
militärflughafen nahe der stadt erwähnt
zeigen bilder anderes von raketen
getroffen ein hochhaus in odessa
mindestens acht menschen sollen nach
ukrainischen angaben gestorben sein
darunter auch ein drei monate altes baby
18 menschen seien verletzt worden aus
der ukraine berichtet dominik
löschmeister
es gibt keine osternacht die sie heute
feiern können in kiew der gottesdienst
in sankt nikolaus ist nachmittags am
abend gilt eine sperrstunde im land im
krieg seiner gemeinde halt geben wichtig
für vater wenig
unser feind ist unmenschlich
wir beten zu gott dass er uns beschützt
und diese feiertage friedlich und ruhig
gefeiert werden können
für die gläubigen zu hause übertragen
sie die messe im internet vor der kirche
empfangen sie den österlichen segen
normalerweise lassen wir samstags den
osterkuchen segnen und selbst jetzt
während der kriegszeit haben wir uns
dazu entschieden wir wollen diesen
feiertag mit unseren freunden feiern
vielerorts in der ukraine wird es keine
ostermesse geben die kirchen zerstört
wie hier in lucka schiff nördlich von
kiel die russen lagerten munition in dem
gotteshaus die ukrainischen streitkräfte
beschossen es um sie zu vertreiben
ostern ohne kirche
welcher gottesdienst die kirchen um uns
herum wurden zerstört dörfer wurden
bombardiert
wir können jetzt nirgendwo hin wir
hatten so eine schöne kirche es ist eine
schande
pasqua so heißt der traditionelle
osterkuchen in der ukraine
man isst ihn zusammen mit der familie
die soldaten und soldatinnen in dieser
stellung vor kiew können ostern nicht
mit ihren liebsten feiern
ich besuche normalerweise meine mutter
aber sie ist in der jetzt besetzten
region hessen dieser feiertag ist
normalerweise wichtig für mich aber
meine familie ist jetzt auch hier
zumindest auf den osterkuchen sollen sie
nicht verzichten die waffen werden nicht
schweigen auch um den feiertag
doch niklas meister ist für uns in kiew
dominik guten abend beginnen wir mit der
orthodoxen osternacht jetzt da war ja in
kiew in den letzten tagen wieder so
etwas wie vorsichtige rückkehr ins leben
zu spüren wie sieht das heute aus
ja man sieht schon menschen tagsüber auf
der straße auch heute an diesem
orthodoxen ostersamstag es gibt cafés
die offen haben restaurants
ich habe heute sogar einen
blumenverkäufer am straßenrand gesehen
aber man muss schon sagen es ist hier
schon noch eine angst zu spüren bei den
menschen die angst dass dieser krieg
auch nach kiew wieder stärker
zurückkommt und dann gucken wir dominik
auf die mögliche strategie russlands da
sorgt jetzt ein hochrangiger russischer
militärkommandeur für aufsehen nach
dessen worten der gesamte süden der
ukraine im visier sei und auch die
angrenzende republik moldau sich
durchaus sorgen machen muss wir schauen
uns die region vielleicht mal auf einer
karte an und können dann hier sehen
straff irrt die mehrheitlich von
russland gehaltenen gebiete orange
eingefärbt die aktuellen umkämpften
regionen gucken jetzt aber vielleicht
mal richtung süden und westen dominik
was könnte diese strategie für diese
gebiete dort bedeuten
ja also die sorge ist groß dass es nicht
nur um den don bass geht sondern auch um
den süden der ukraine also die
hafenstadt odessa und transnistrien das
ist eine abtrünnige republik der
republik moldau und transnistrien wird
von den russen kontrolliert das sind
auch russische truppen und war der
republik moldau gibt es natürlich jetzt
große sorge dass diese diese diese diese
diese linie jetzt gezogen wird
transnistrien quasi über die süd ukraine
bis in den donnerstag
kein nato mitglied im gegensatz zum
beispiel zu polen und dem baltikum das
ist natürlich bisher nur ein szenario
aber präsident zuletzt gewarnt die
europäer davor dass ja die ukraine nicht
das letzte ziel der russischen invasoren
sein könnte neue sorgen am orthodoxen
osterfest dominik erst mal ist der live
in kiew herzlichen dank dominik der
krieg in der ukraine und die deutsche
haltung dazu ist längst streitthema in
der innenpolitik bei uns er bestimmt
auch einen fdp parteitag der besonderen
art mit einem vorsitzenden der wegen
corona infektion nur mit technischen
problemen von weit weg dabei sein kann
und mit einer partei die ihren kurs
sucht zwischen koalitionsfrieden und
kritik am kanzler christian von
rechenberg berichtet schön dich
wiederzusehen nach zwei jahren ein
parteitag in präsenz die delegierten in
berlin beinahe in partylaune sie währt
nur kurz weicht der debatte um
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und den
weg dorthin sie geht voran marie agnes
strack zimmermann ist omnipräsent ist um
nie gesucht und setzt den ton das gebot
der stunde heißt den ukrainern wie in
unserem antrag gefordert auch schwere
waffen zu liefern
die ukraine muss sich zur wehr setzen
können
alles gesagt der parteitag feiert seine
identifikationsfigur eigentlich ihm
zugeschrieben doch parteichef lindner
ist in corona quarantäne aus den usa nur
zugeschaltet technisch nicht ganz
fehlerfrei gesundheitlich angeschlagen
mahnt er zu enger abstimmung mit den
nato partnern wir müssen alles was in
unserer macht steht tun um der ukraine
zum sieg zu verhelfen
aber die verantwortungs ethische grenze
ist die gefährdung unserer eigenen
sicherheit
bloß nicht kriegspartei werden trotzdem
entschlossen handeln der bundesvorstand
hat dazu einen antrag vorgelegt 11
punkte vielen geht er nicht weit genug
die ukraine braucht auf jeden fall nur
unterstützung neuer durch waffen ich
persönlich gehöre auch zu den vertretern
der these dass wir auch aus deutschland
etwas anliefern schwere waffen ja
brauchen wir auch aber wir müssen immer
abwägen wie wir uns in deutschland
positionieren und ich denke der
ringtausch zum beispiel das ist eine
möglichkeit mit der wir gute arbeiten
könnten auch er ergreift das wort wie
chang gießerei heute zum generalsekretär
gewählt der gebürtige iraner hat
diktatur und krieg erlebt zieht den
vergleich zum minsk und moskau jede form
der wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit mit
diesen regimen ist eine schande sie muss
schnellstmöglich beendet werden der
parteitag beschließt am abend genau das
und er sendet ein entschiedenes jahr für
schwere waffen wie sehen die ukraine
kommen und von bleibt offen hauptsache
sagt strack zimmermann
es ist offiziell
schwarz auf weiß
ja und dann guckt die fdp natürlich
gespannt darauf wie ihr
koalitionspartner im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland dasteht
dort will cdu ministerpräsident hendrik
wüst seine erste wahl als regierungschef
gewinnen was immer in nrw passiert es
schlägt auf die stimmung bundesweit
alter wahlkampfspruch der sich immer
wieder bewahrheitet und auch jetzt
gelten dürfte denn erfolg oder
misserfolg auch des neuen cdu
bundesvorsitzenden zeigt sich in dessen
heimat nordrhein-westfalen am 15 mai ist
dort war heute beginnt die heiße phase
im wahlkampf
ralph goldmann hat mehr
es ist eine große inszenierung heute
mittag in düsseldorf und es ist
wahlkampf premiere für ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst vor sechs monaten hatte er
das amt von armin laschet übernommen
jetzt geht er erst einmal auf attacke in
richtung bundeskanzler olaf scholz der
blockiere die lieferung schwerer waffen
für die ukraine die deutsche
bundesregierung hat immer lange gezögert
und gezaudert
noch nie war deutschland so teilnahmslos
und isoliert in europa wie heute der
zauber kurs des kanzlers und der spd ist
ein schlimmer gewesen aus berlin ist
friedrich merz nach düsseldorf gekommen
begrüßt demonstrativ eine delegation aus
der ukraine
von olaf scholz erwartet der nächste
woche im bundestag eine
regierungserklärung und eine aussprache
sagt er falls nicht werde die union
einen eigenen antrag stellen es gibt ja
im deutschen bundestag eine mehrheit für
waffen die fohlen auch für schwere
waffen an die ukraine
cdu/csu fdp und grüne sind dafür die spd
zögert ich biete der spd auch
ausdrücklich an dass wir einen
gemeinsamen antrag in den deutschen
bundestag einbringen so sticht
bundespolitik derzeit in nrw deutlich
landespolitik wüst herausforderer thomas
kutschaty von der spd wirbt derweil an
duisburger haustüren um wählerstimmen
ihm kann die diskussion um den
bundeskanzler nicht recht sein
vielleicht sogar schaden die cdu hat
ganz offensichtlich ein wahlkampf
problem in nordrhein-westfalen sonst
würde sie solche aggressiven töne
überhaupt nicht benutzen gibt überhaupt
keinen anlass daran zu zweifeln dass
olaf scholz und die bundesregierung
genau die richtigen schritte unternehmen
werden waffen in die ukraine geliefert
aber mit bedacht in den jüngsten
umfragen liegt die spd inzwischen sogar
knapp vor der cdu vielleicht auch wegen
der sogenannten mallorca affäre um
umweltministerin ursula heinen esser von
der cdu die musste zurücktreten weil sie
nach der flutkatastrophe den geburtstag
ihres mannes auf mallorca gefeiert hatte
gestern dann traf die spd die so
genannte spionageaffäre ein mitarbeiter
der fraktion hat er der 16 jährigen
tochter der ex umweltministerin eine
kontaktanfrage bei instagram gestellt
möglicherweise um dort belastendes
material zu finden
für die wählenden wird all das aber kaum
eine rolle spielen glaubt der
parteienforscher karl-rudolf korte
das rennen sei völlig offen man kann
sogar soweit gehen dass vielleicht auch
der zweite am wahlabend am ende noch
sieger werden kann nicht der
mehrheitsführer wird automatisch
ministerpräsident sondern der beste
sondieren denn einer dieser beiden wird
am ende vielleicht die grünen und die
fdp brauchen um das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland regieren zu können ampel oder
jamaika das sind derzeit die
wahrscheinlichsten koalitionen in nrw
so und jetzt weitere wichtige
nachrichten an diesem samstag und die
hat hanna die eu hat sich auf ein neues
digital gesetz geeinigt dass online
nutzer besser schützen soll was offline
illegal ist soll künftig auch online
verboten sein dazu gehören zum beispiel
hass und hetze gewaltaufrufe und
desinformationen aber auch der verkauf
gefälschter produkte unternehmen wie
google maps oder emerson müssen illegale
inhalte künftig zeitnah löschen sobald
sie ihnen gemeldet werden plattformen
drohen hohe geldstrafen wenn sie die
neuen bestimmungen systematisch
missachten das europaparlament und die
eu staaten müssen dem gesetz noch
zustimmen
in kraft tritt es frühestens 2023
im vergangenen jahr hatten die grünen in
baden württemberg einen parteiausschluss
gegen den tübinger oberbürgermeister
boris palmer beschlossen nun hat das
landesschiedsgericht einen vergleich
vorgeschlagen bis ende 2023 soll palmer
seine mitgliedschaft ruhen lassen
außerdem soll in gesprächen geklärt
werden wie der politiker in zukunft
kontroverse meinungen äußern kann ohne
gegen die ordnung der partei zu
verstoßen grund für das
ausschlussverfahren sind umstrittene
äußerungen des politikers
etwa 2000 menschen haben immer und
nordrhein westfälischen lutzerath am
rande des tagebaus garzweiler gegen den
abbau von braunkohle demonstriert zudem
wollen sie verhindern dass der bereits
verlassenen ort für die
braunkohleförderung abgebaggert wird
zu der kundgebung hatten unter anderem
der umweltverband un de suisse und
friday future aufgerufen
bei einer heftigen explosion in einer
illegalen ölraffinerie im südosten
nigerias sind dutzende menschen ums
leben gekommen
zur genauen zahl der toten gibt es
unterschiedliche angaben medienberichten
unter berufung auf behördenvertreter von
mindestens 50 toten
die genaue ursache des unglücks ist noch
nicht bekannt
in venedig hat die biennale heute ihre
pforten für kunstbegeisterte aus aller
welt geöffnet und gleich am ersten tag
wurden die wichtigsten preise des
festivals vergeben zwei der goldenen
löwen gingen an die schwarzen
künstlerinnen sonja boys und simon lee
für ihr lebenswerk wurde die
düsseldorfer künstlerin katharina
fritsch geehrt die biennale gilt als
eines der wichtigsten foren für
gegenwartskunst bis ende november werden
1500 arbeiten präsentiert außerdem sind
80 länder mit eigenen pavillons teil der
biennale
und noch die sport meldung des tages der
fc bayern münchen hat es wieder einmal
geschafft die mannschaft von trainer
julian nagelsmann ist meister der
fußball bundesliga mit einem 3 1 gegen
erzrivale dortmund besiegelten die
münchner den vorzeitigen titelgewinn
es ist der zehnte meistertitel in folge
und insgesamt der 32 jetzt die
lottozahlen die lauten 13
29 32 34 38 47 und die superzahl 6 alle
angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
fehlt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten
morgen bleibt es im norden bei einem mix
aus sonne und wolken trocken im süden
überwiegen die wolken dazu gibt es
südlich der donau gewittrige schauer
sonst regnet es auch länger im norden
weht ein lebhafter nordost wind die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 8 bis 18
grad am montag regnet es im westen und
süden am dienstag im süden am mittwoch
überwiegt dann wieder der sonnenschein
und es wird mit 12 bis 18 grad etwas
wärmer
so wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
zwar sehr gerne und gucken dann auf eine
entscheidende wahl für europa wenn klar
wird wer künftig in frankreich regiert
bis dahin wünschen wir ihnen erst mal
einen schönen abend und die nächsten
nachrichten gibt's hier gegen 0.30 heute
express
[Musik]